Things that can make you sick:
allergens, contaminated food and water, and
racism!
Hey folks, welcome to Dnews.
Laci Green here.
My favorite commercials are those ones that
are like, "Did you know that stress is terrible
for your health?"
Yea!
Stress can lead to high blood pressure, and
supressed immune system, and diabetes.
And then you're like, "Oh great!
Now I get to be stressed out about being stressed
out."
Man!
Stress is like a bad cycle.
And it's a cycle that affects some folks more
than others.
A new study published in the Journal of Sociological
Inquiry found that after analyzing data from
30,000 people, racial minorites had significatly
higher rates of stress.
And it's symbolic of a great divide between
the health of the dominant race versus the
minority race in countries around the world.
It's well documented that minority groups
in the U.S. have way more stress, poor mental
health and poor physical health than white
Americans.
Racial minorities get sick more, their illness
gets more severe, it happens at younger ages,
and they die sooner than white people do.
In the U.S., New Zealand, and Canada, the
average lifespan of male minorities is seven
years shorter than the white male average
in the country.
In Australia, it's twenty one years shorter.
So the big question here is, "Why?"
It's a tricky puzzle, peeps, with lotsa pieces,
more than a short YouTube video could ever
hope to place.
But there are a few key factors here: racial
discrimination, class, and education level.
A study at the University of Western Australia
found that aboriginal participants were five
times as likely to report negative treatment
based on their race and twice as likely to
have health problems.
The American Journal of Public Health found
that even anticipating racism, which minorities
commonly experience with racial profiling
policies like "Stop and Frisk," is enough
to trigger a harmful stress response.
The British Medical Journal published a study
finding that those who initially screened
a negative for all mental illnesses, were
twice as likely to have detereorating mental
health when they experience racial discrimination.
So these are some of the reasons why scientists
are calling for racial prejudices, from interpersonal
type, like being suspicious of someone because
they're black, to systemic types, like providing
a little funding for schools in the "ghetto,"
can be addressed not only as a social justice
issue, but a public health issue.
At a conference in Switzerland last week focused
on addressing racial health disparities, researchers
laid out what they think can be done about
this.
The first, is to recognize that there's something
that's not quite right here.
Second is to say, "Nu uh!
Inequality is not cool!"
And lastly, to make real changes that will
better the health of minority groups.
So, next stop, end global poverty!
Thanks for joining me friends.
Don't forget to subscribe to Dnews for two
new science updates every single day!
Yea, that's how much we love you.
I'll see you next time.